there's a very interesting new report
out which finds that Russia has
interfered in the elections and politics
of 19 countries over the last two
decades the report is titled Putin's
asymmetric assault on democracy in
Russia and Europe implications for US
national security
it's a horrible title for a report but
trust me the content of the report is
really interesting it was released a
couple days ago it's over 200 pages it
was prepared for the Senate Committee on
Foreign Relations now you might be
saying okay so what do we care what
Russia did in other countries over the
last 20 years well it makes the denials
about Russian interference in our
election in 2016
even more difficult to take seriously
from Republicans and from some people on
the Left here's the list of countries
according to the report where Russia
interfered in elections over the last
couple of decades Ukraine Georgia
Montenegro Serbia Bulgaria Hungary
Latvia Lithuania Estonia Denmark Finland
Norway Sweden the Netherlands UK France
Germany Spain and Italy quite a list
right so why not the United States this
is what they do or do you believe that
all of these reports from these 19
countries over the last 20 years are
also fake because once you grant that
this is what Russia does why is it so
hard to believe that they did it in the
United States as well right and it's a
very similar mo in other countries
number one Russia would work to spread
misinformation we saw that in the 2016
election we know about the Twitter and
Facebook ad buys we know about the
social media troll and bought accounts
we know about the fake news sites we
know about all of those mechanisms and
that matches what Russia has been doing
al biet with different exact
technologies and social media wasn't
around 20 years ago it matches what
Russia has done in 19 other countries
Russia in other countries in order to
interfere with the politics and
elections of other countries funded
far-right political causes go back to
the book from the 1990s the foundations
of geopolitics where it
outlines Russia's strategies for
interfering in other countries including
in the US and it includes try to
escalate racial tensions a great way to
do that is by funding extreme right-wing
groups another way to do that which
Russia did in the United States was
geo-targeting people in Ferguson
Missouri and I believe it was in
Baltimore Maryland during the time of
unrest there what Russia is accused of
having done in the United States during
the 2016 election matches exactly with
what this report found that they did in
19 other countries over a two decade
period and at some point what's that
phrase if it looks like a duck if it
smells like a duck if it walks like a
duck quacks like a duck if it tastes
like a duck one might say although not
vegan appropriate it's probably a duck
at some point right or maybe there's the
new way to say it if you watch those CNN
commercials is an apple is an Apple no
matter what you call it not a banana
it's not a banana it's not an orange
it's not a persimmon even try persimmon
though it's a nice nice little fruit so
what we're learning is that the stunning
part isn't that someone would allege
Russia interfered in our election that
that's kind of the obvious part that's
the believable part the stunning part is
increasingly that anyone would think to
deny that Russia would have done this
and here's a quote from the report
nearly 20 years ago Vladimir Putin
gained and solidified power by
exploiting blackmail fears of terrorism
and war since then he has combined
military adventurism and aggression
abroad with propaganda and political
repression at home to persuade a
domestic audience that he is restoring
Russia to greatness and a respected
position on the world stage all the
while he has empowered the state
security services and employed them to
consolidate his hold on the levers of
political social and economic power
which he has used to make himself and a
circle of loyalists extraordinarily
wealthy you know in reading that it
feels a lot like what Donald Trump is
doing in the United States he is using
political power government power trying
to use legislative
judicial power to consolidate his status
and the status of his friends cronies
and family members and a bunch of the
people on his cabinet to become even
wealthier than they were going into this
entire thing what about what we can do
right that's the next question let's
assume that now I'm talking to the
reasonable people who understand
Russia's been doing this for decades
they did in the United States the exact
same thing that they did in other
countries for decades what can we do to
prevent them from continuing to do this
to our elections in the future very long
list the report includes something like
30 or more examples but a couple things
are number one sanctions sanctions do
work if they're appropriate if they are
strong enough and they are targeted in
the right way requiring disclosure by
social media platforms of who is funding
their political ads and that is a sort
of twofold effect if social media
platforms know that if they take this
foreign money it will be public
information they would be less likely to
do it and also to some degree it's
possible that the foreign powers if they
know that it will be public that they
bought ads and tried to exert influence
maybe they'd also be less likely to do
the ad buys although I think for Putin
he would love the idea of that going
public because the the goal is just to
create chaos but at least from the point
of view of Twitter if your Twitter and
you know in advance we accept this money
from the Russians it's gonna have to be
disclosed publicly we don't want to end
up testifying before Congress again
let's just refuse the money that
impossible
another thing would just be to not have
a deal financial or otherwise with one
of the American candidates oh they're
way to stop this from happening again
that would be another another way to do
it if we had candidates who did not
actually go ahead and do this but if
it's that their advantage to do it of
course they're going to if especially if
you're someone like Trump what else is
relevant here to people who have been
following the facts closely none of this
will be surprising but it is kind of an
interesting new way to talk to the
deniers which is someone says to you I
don't believe any of it I don't believe
Russia did anything with the US election
okay well do you accept the report that
says Russia did this in 19 countries
over 20 years if they say yes I do
accept that
then you say okay well if they did it in
1900 over 20 years why don't you believe
they were able to do it in the US and if
they say no I don't believe they did it
in any of those countries then you have
to say well how could all of these
different reports and sources write 19
different countries why would they all
lie that Russia tried to influence their
election just doesn't make any sense it
doesn't mean like there's that baseline
position that Russia interferes with
elections in general there's a step up
which is that Russia interfered with the
u.s. election in 2016 a step up from
that is specifically they did that to
help Trump and that maybe the other one
is illusion angle right well then
there's also another one which is yes
they interfered to help Trump and they
swung the election yeah and you can deny
you can not believe although I've seen a
mathematical case made that actually
Russian interference could have swayed
the election because the margins were so
thin in some key states but put that
aside you can believe that Russia didn't
succeed at swinging the results of the
election that doesn't exculpate them of
everything that they did they might just
not have done enough of it to swing the
election that's not really a defense in
my ID and you have to draw the line
somewhere and where you draw that line
depends on the evidence that people have
put forward right you have to weigh that
and think critically about it so just
remember this report now when you hear
people haphazard haphazardly and sort of
in a blanket way say there was no way
that Russia did this there's no reason
to believe Russia did this well Russia
did the exact same thing they have a
decades-long track record of doing send
me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show it's the Friday show